hey guys so you just bought a brand new
game for your PC you boot up and what's
the very first thing that you do know
before you start in your game and before
you turn off subtitles and before you
invert the x-axis on your mouse no wait
because who would do that before all of
those things if you're anything like me
anyway you jump straight into the
graphics settings and begin tweaking
fortunately due to my huge cranial
capacity I can indeed distinguish
between the terms low medium and high
but it's all those advanced graphics
settings that can cause problems so many
strange words numbers and bloody
abbreviations what does it all mean well
if you're the same then fear not because
over the course of the next two episodes
of reality check I'm going to
investigate these different terms and
figure out exactly what they mean and
also what they do to give you those
sweet sexy graphics ok let's start with
the easy one resolution this is simply a
measure of the number of horizontal
pixels by the number of vertical pixels
being output by the display unlike with
console gaming there are typically a
bunch of different options available for
PC at a load of weird and wonderful
aspect ratios so why does resolution
matter well ultimately the higher
resolution you display at the more
detail you get and therefore the better
the image it also helps prevent unwanted
graphical oddities like aliasing and
speaking of which have you ever looked
really closely while playing a game and
noticed some of the edges can appear
Jaggi well this is because of aliasing
and it's an artifact of displaying
digital graphics you see any object in a
video game is ultimately made out of
pixels the straight lines don't have any
issues but as soon as you try to draw a
diagonal things go a bit weird and bumpy
ok let's use Photoshop to demonstrate
this here is a straight line of pixels
all is good a nice crisp edge however if
I try to draw something at an angle now
suddenly things get old Jaggi
now what anti-aliasing does is try to
get rid of those jagged edges and make
everything look silky smooth by
changing the color of pixels around the
edge so that there's a gradual blend of
color interestingly you can turn this on
as an effect in Photoshop check it out
now if we zoom out a little much
smoother while anti-aliasing can have a
substantial effect on image quality it
is pretty heavy on the old processor
because has to render all those extra
color pixels thankfully though there are
a number of different types of
anti-aliasing to choose from multisample
anti-aliasing or MSA a this tries to be
smarter and less demanding on your
machine by applying itself only to the
parts of each frame that will look
jagged rather than the whole image it's
selective really on where and what it
works on fast approximate anti-aliasing
or fxaa
now this is the fastest and least
process heavy mode of all anti-aliasing
the reason is that it doesn't use high
resolution frame data instead it's
applied straight to the pixels on screen
at the resolution you're playing at it's
more blurry and doesn't look quite as
good but it's significantly less
demanding temporal anti-aliasing TX a a
sometimes mla a okay this is potentially
the best one this is a bit like ms AAA
but with an extra step you see TxAA
takes into account previous frames to
produce its own next frame by averaging
the colors also the final way to be
aliasing which i mentioned earlier is
our old friend resolution you just need
more of it check it out here we have
another lovely blue line except this
time it's at a much higher resolution in
fact this is at 4k this time if we turn
the high resolution line to the diagonal
without anti-aliasing well you don't
really notice those jaggies at all now
they are still there
if we zoom right in you can see but the
resolution is so great the size of each
pixel relative to the whole shape is
much smaller and so that stare effect is
really reduced the fact that 4k aliasing
pretty much stops being an issue
altogether
if you're trying to push your machine to
the limit with a brand new processor
intensive game aliasing is not the only
thing to worry about you've also got to
contend with the dreaded screen tear
screen tear happens when your graphics
card and your display aren't really on
the same page it's all to do with frame
rate and refresh rate so when you're
running around shooting wildlife in Far
Cry 3 your graphics card is hard at work
outputting frames at a hopefully steady
rate this is measured in frames per
second or fps your monitor on the other
hand is also refreshing its display at a
set rate per second called the refresh
rate now if these are out of sync it can
result in your display refreshing and
showing information from two or more
frames at the same time leading to the
appearance of nasty tears and this is
exactly what vsync aims to mitigate now
it does so by locking the frame rate
output of your graphics card to match
the refresh rate of your monitor in
reality though this does come with its
own issues as it can cause the gameplay
to stutter
whenever the GPU frame rate drops below
the display refresh rate this usually
happens when there's a whole lot of
stuff going on on-screen at once
interestingly though Nvidia have come up
with a cool new solution for this and is
called G sync the tag which is built
into special monitors enables the
display to refresh as soon as it gets a
new frame meaning it can match exactly
the output of the graphics card so with
G sync the monitor is keeping toe-to-toe
with a GPU rather than the other way
around this in theory lets you get the
absolute best performance and frame rate
from your machine
okay time to stop fixing problems and
start just making things look awesome
now all objects in video games are made
up of larger units called polygons
tessellation basically means taking a
polygon and breaking it up into smaller
bits so why is this useful well allows
your PC to generate greater detail in
the object using these smaller parts
it's particularly useful for generating
height and depth with tessellation
developers can apply displacement Maps
basically maps of height information to
a polygon and the tessellation will
calculate and generate the appropriate
level of depth making for more realistic
images this also helps with creating
nice smooth rounded objects
well I don't know about you guys but
that's about all the technical graphics
jargon I can handle for this episode so
make sure you come back next week when
we'll chat SSAO depth of field texture
filtering motion blur and maybe some
physics as well oh and for a deep dive
into frame rates and whether they matter
for gaming check at my previous episode
of reality check
do we need 60 FPS on ps4 and Xbox one
remember if you think I've missed
anything in this episode or if there's
anything in particular you like me to
mention next week do you let me know in
the comments down below or by dropping
me a tweet at cam 4 as Rob okay guys see
you next week